all right let's go to Jorge from South
Florida I will soon be in South Florida
and it's going to be pretty explosive I
think hortica
hey David how's it going it's going well
wonderful so I'm gonna make it really
quick because I know you won good
question so I got two questions please
one is a ideological question that I
want to ask if you can tag a little bit
on I could I've got people here in South
Florida talk about the whole difference
between nationalism and patriotism yep
and I've come to the conclusion that
it's very similar but it's very
different at the same time okay what's
your take on that
uh I don't know that I sorry did I cut
you off there
no I'm sorry I'm sorry I asked
afterwards sorry I'm not totally sure I
understand the question
so I think that I was raised in Spain
you think that you were raised in Spain
or you were raised in Spain
sorry I was raised in Spain okay I think
in my idea that the difference would be
nationalism being something that the
government tells you you gotta love the
country opposed to patriotism being you
love the country because you love where
you live does that make sense yeah we
feel we did like a patriotism versus
nationalism thing
um you know here's the thing there I
have two thoughts on this one thought is
this is a meaningful distinction and
there's something about
patriotism is not
condescending or discriminatory or
oppressive whereas nationalism can be
right that's like one view I guess the
other view would be we're really just
kind of arguing about semantics and both
and and patriotism can be just as toxic
as nationalism depending on what you
mean by it I don't know I I'm not really
sure to be totally honest I do think I
do think
for example in Argentina
one of the things a lot of argentinians
will mention to me when they come to the
US is there's just so many American
flags out like all the time and it's
weird for two reasons it's weird on the
one hand because it does feel more
nationalistic than patriotic but also it
also loses meaning when the flags are
out all the time we're like in Argentina
people don't just tend to display flags
all the time but like there's a flag day
and people display flags that day it
seems more meaningful because it's a
specific day but also in Argentina the
people displaying the flags
aren't more likely to be the Nationalist
types like in the U.S so so I do think
there's definitely a difference in the
U.S when it comes to Flags nationalism
and patriotism I just don't know that I
would focus on the difference between
nationalism and patriotism
that makes sense thank you
um that makes sense my other question
would be
as an Argentinian I gotta bet for my
wife on this one do you eat Asados or no
yes I do yeah oh okay I I just had a
feeling that you were more uh by what
you publicize more like plant-based diet
so I thought maybe you weren't into
Asados okay I don't eat a lot of red
meat but when I go to Argentina you know
and and of course yes absolutely yeah oh
okay thank you David did you win the bet
or lose it
I lost it you lost it all right well I
apologize all right according from South
Florida very very good lost to bed and
we can all uh sort of explore explore
that further